the u.s is preparing to send another 3
billion with the b dollars in military
aid to ukraine as that country marks six
months they call it an anniversary of
the russian invasion of that country
it's also ukraine's independence day
right now and they are marking it
officials there are worried however that
russia may launch new attacks to disrupt
the occasion deborah patta is in kiev
that's ukraine's capital uh deborah good
morning
good morning well kiva is celebrating
its independence with this display of
wrecked russian tanks that you see
behind me it was six months ago that the
unthinkable became reality when vladimir
putin invaded ukraine and i should warn
you that some of the visuals you're
about to see are disturbing
it is ukraine's signature brand defiance
not fear which is how they've chosen to
face this uneasy day
very different from last year's
celebrations the country's wartime
president has long swapped his suit for
military fatigue
he set the tone when he raised the
familiar yellow and blue flag boldly
proclaiming it would once again fly over
the whole country including crimea but
it is a day fraught with danger amid
fears russia will spoil the party by
ramping up attacks repugnant russian
provocations are possible warned
president zelinski respect curfew and
act on air raid sirens
economist andre gligac says half a year
of fighting has taught ukraine that
standing up to russia is the only way to
deal with a bully we shouldn't
be afraid of putin
or
of war we should be
as brave as possible
to be open and to be ready for the new
world but it's come at a terrible price
we are trying to find a way how to not
only survive but to to win quickly in
order to save ukrainian infrastructure
save your creating economics and first
of all save our lives
keeve is the defining symbol of that
ukrainian bravery putin's hopes of a
swift victory came to nothing as he was
prevented from seizing the capital
instead civilians who fled to the
countryside of butcher and european bore
the brunt of a month of terror unleashed
by russian forces
by now ukrainians are used to constant
air raid sirens which are once again
sounding the alarm in kiev and in russia
where this is not even referred to as a
war but a special military operation
questions are surfacing
i really don't understand who needs this
war said russian cemetery assistant olga
grazinova the mothers too keep asking
who needs this war
and six months on here we are with these
destroyed russian tanks a reminder that
putin's hopes of a swift victory parade
down this very road have been halted by
a nation that is fighting to hold on to
its freedom tony
deborah pedophorus in ukraine